hi fair
hi martin
fair you are a principal serverless
specialist i've heard that means that
you spend a lot of time with businesses
who are moving to the cloud
i sure do
i'd love to hear if they know about
serverless and if so what their thoughts
are
happy to share
[Music]
all right i really enjoy building
serverless apps with cloud run but do
engineering managers and ctos know what
serverless is
well they look at the bigger picture the
development process passes through
several stages before software is
delivered to their customers they think
about how to make each step cost
effective and predictable
okay that makes sense
let's start with the first step
provisioning it can be a lot of work to
set up all the virtual machines needed
for an enterprise application and ctos
know that their bosses get upset if they
get it wrong if they over provision the
business is paying too much if they
underprovision the application doesn't
run properly one way to make this step
easier
and less risky is to go serverless with
cloud run
cloud run scales up and down with
traffic and setup is easy ctos like that
predictability
i can see that
what about the second step in your
diagram as a developer i really enjoy
that step
many ctos and engineering managers don't
enjoy it as much as you do for them this
step is often a bottleneck it's hard for
them to find good developers with the
right skills coding ability kubernetes
experience linux operations etc
yeah well that sounds hard i mean i
don't know all that stuff right but
there is a way to streamline this step
instead of trying to find a team of
all-round developers superstars
many ctos focus on picking a platform
that makes regular developers productive
serverless platforms like cloud run help
here
developers who know one or two
programming languages can be productive
they don't need to be programmers and
i.t operations experts
oh good to know that there's a place for
regular developers in the world
okay what about the release step
in this step ctos and engineering
managers are looking for increased
automation to achieve faster time to
market one way to do this is to use
build packs instead of docker these
reduce the operational burden on
developers while supporting enterprise
operators who manage apps at scale
yeah i know docker but i use build packs
all the time anyway it means fewer
moving parts in my application
right butte packs can also make it
easier to meet security and compliance
requirements without developer
intervention with cloud run you can
choose whether you want to use docker
files or building build packs if you use
build packs you can go straight from
source code to production
okay
and then there's the run step in your
diagram
enterprise applications are often
complex and hard to keep running ctos
know that the business loses money when
the applications go down for example
they might lose their ability to talk to
their customers
to take orders to charge their customers
or their employees may be forced to cite
either when enterprise application goes
down
how do they prevent those outages
ctos know that complexity is the enemy
in this step one way to reduce
complexity is to let your cloud provider
handle it
cloud run does this by abstracting away
the infrastructure and it's fully
integrated with cloud monitoring and
cloud logging for an enhanced operator
experience
all right thank you very much for
sharing this with us today fair and
thank you everyone for watching if you
have questions for me or fair please add
them in the comments also write in the
comments if you have topics for other
surplus things we should talk about in
the show thank you for today
[Music]
you